hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
it's a twenty-third of March and you're
watching games but news dragon age
inquisition first single player
expansion pack is coming out tomorrow
for Xbox one and PC the DLC is called
jaws of hack on and while it will be
coming to Microsoft's platforms first it
will eventually also make its way to ps4
the DLC out at the moment for
Inquisition includes packs like the
destruction and the deluxe upgrade which
adds new pubs to existing destinations
as well as a bunch of equipment hi We're
have announced they'll be releasing both
the trailer for the DLC as well as the
expansion itself tomorrow which may have
been hacked today but they still have a
thing or two to say about the way Xbox
and Playstation are running their
business Emmett shear founder of twitch
has said that the seven year upgrade
cycles the consoles is way too long he
also said you suspect there won't be
another generation of consoles and that
xbox and playstation will need to change
form explaining I could imagine a
version 1.1 product from both Microsoft
and Sony which adds in slightly more
speed and slightly more memory very
similar to how phones and tablets work
today I think it's going to look more
like the mobile phone market over time
she has said he thinks this sort of
evolution would make consoles more like
set-top boxes and subsequently result in
short life cycles between upgrades holy
batman use Batman we have all of it the
only question is short the good news or
the bad news well the good news is
Arkham City and Arkham Asylum are slated
to get ps4 and xbox one remasters if a
recent report from IGN Italy is to be
believed the publication claims that the
two games will arrive by Christmas
although Warner Brothers has not
confirmed the news what has been
confirmed though and this is your bad
news portion is that Batman Arkham
Knight has been delayed again originally
meant to launch in 2014 and subsequently
push to june two
this year the game is now jus out on jun
23 although i really wouldn't commit
that new release date to memory if
history serves is any indication at
least Rocksteady released a cool new ps4
trailer to soften the blow with seven
minutes of that many goodness let me
know down in the comments what you think
of the delay and the new trailer you can
head to gamespot we've got news on
Twitter's potential hack and no more God
of War II masters those are all the
things that I want to tell you about
today i'll be back same time tomorrow
with more news so i hope to see you then